Before we can begin to use the Niagara fluids in our project, we need to enable the Niagara
fluid plugin. Now this is pretty simple to do. All we need to do is go to the Plugins menu,
look for FX, and then there is Niagara fluid and we just enable it and restart the editor.
I'm going to go ahead and do that now. So inside of my editor, I'm going to come over
to the Plugins menu, bring this on the screen here, go over to our FX, and we're going to
look for Niagara fluids and we are going to enable that. And then we're going to hit Restart
Now. Once we have done that, we are going to then right click on the Content Browser,
go to Niagara System, and then we will be able to select this little wizard here. And
if we click on Niagara fluids, we will then have the ability to see all of the different
Niagara fluids that we have access to. So let's just pop back over here to the editor
and have a look at that now. So again, hit Control Space. I'm going to disable my Level
Filter. Come up to my Content, right click, and then from the menu here, select the Niagara
System. And we're going to go to Niagara fluids. And if we want, we can go 2D, 2D Liquid, 3D
Gas, 3D Liquid. There is some shallow water is the last one I wanted to show you, or we
can look at all of them here. And all we need to do to select one of these and use it as
the basis is simply just select it and then hit Create. Now, once we do that behind the
scenes, what is actually going on here is our Niagara is built off of very, very, very
complex inheritance. And inheritance in our case is actually used to progressively add
more and more functionality. So instead of all of the fluid behavior being done in one
single module, and we use that one single module to do everything, we have it kind of
split up like this. So we have our basic three grid 3D gas emitter at the base here. And
then from that, we have the grid gas control. So these are going to be controls that control
this. And then we further refine those. We have some controls for just a regular emitter.
And then we have some controls for our cinematic version or a higher quality version. And then
finally, we actually have our Niagara system that we are going to be creating. So the Niagara
system is what we just created here using one of these, the grid 2D flip hose, or the
3D flip hose or something like that, that would be the Niagara system. And that system,
again, it's going to be made up of a collection of these different Niagara admitters. Now,
the reason I'm bringing this up is because inheritance or knowing that inheritance plays
a functionality here is going to be a key to expanding upon these emitters in the future.
Or it's just important to know that all of this stuff is built upon multiple emitters, and not
just one single massive emitter.